hello and welcome to the summer 2011
edition of rochford district matters the
information paper for the people of
rochford district
in this edition are articles on
volunteering in your community results
of the local elections
the digital switchover
local sports pitches
have your say postcards and much more
but we're going to start with blue bags
for glad rags
did you know that you can now recycle
your unwanted textiles at the curbside
essex textiles a locally based company
are now operating in partnership with
the council to collect textiles for
recycling
the textiles will be collected
fortnightly in blue transparent bags
which should be left alongside your grey
recyclables bin on your collection day
from 7 a.m
there's no limit to the number of bags
you can present
if you run out of bags you can contact
essex textiles and they'll deliver some
more
all we ask is that you don't place the
bags inside your recyclables bin
if you live in a flat you can leave the
bags by your communal bins on your
recyclables collection day
if you live in a residential home please
ask the warden for details
the types of items that you can place in
the textile bags are
clothes
curtains
bedding towels
handbags
hats
cloths
belts and shoes paired and in a usable
condition
unfortunately the scheme can't accept
stained clothing quilts
pillows
rugs or carpets
for more information on the scheme or to
order blue bags please contact essex
textiles on free phone oh 800 787-9071
you can email
barry at essex textiles dot co dot uk or
visit www dot essex textiles dot co dot
uk and follow the links for rochford
you should receive a copy of the
council's recycling calendar for 2011
12.
this calendar tells you which
collections take place on which dates to
help you recycle more
rochford residents are already among the
top recyclers in the country and we hope
the calendar helps
if you have any queries or if you have
not received the recycling calendar
phone our customer services team on zero
one seven zero two
three one eight one double one
getting into volunteering raths center
can help you take the first steps
think volunteering is boring think again
whether it's the extreme high adrenaline
thrill of skydiving 3000 feet from a
plane for charity or showing the next
david beckham how to play football
you're volunteering
there are hundreds of opportunities to
choose from that use a skill you already
have that you are passionate about or
that you can do to make a difference for
example you could coach a local football
team befriend an older person
design a charities website walk
someone's dog present a radio show in a
hospital
help plant trees
what can you gain from volunteering
increasing your confidence
learn new skills gain experience improve
your cv
receive training gain accreditation be
active in your retirement
many employers now ask what volunteering
you have done on their job application
forms
if you are thinking about volunteering
then rayleigh rochefort and district
association for voluntary service revs
volunteer center is a great place to
start to find out more about the
diversity of volunteering roles in the
community and how to get involved
whether you are looking for something to
do as a family would like to learn new
skills build up your cv and experience
or have free time and would like to help
your community there is something for
everyone
rad's volunteer center has a database of
more than 160 volunteering opportunities
in a variety of areas
to find out more about how we can help
you to find the right volunteering role
contact amanda harris or jeanette helson
on
oh one two six eight double seven two
seven nine six visit their website at
www.ravs.org dot uk
email volunteering at ravs.co dot uk or
visit 105 a high street rayleigh ss-67qa
volunteer center news in brief over the
past year rav's volunteer center has
processed volunteering applications for
over 600 people
placed 160 volunteers in the rochford
district
helped over 60 organizations secure
volunteers
continued to work with other volunteer
centers across essex
in order to gain accreditation to the
national governing body for volunteering
volunteering england
celebrated the contribution by
volunteers to our local community by
holding an annual volunteer awards
ceremony during volunteers week first to
the 7th of june
i live outside the district can i still
get involved
for those living outside the district
wanting to volunteer they can find many
other interesting opportunities
on the volunteer essex website
www.volunteeressex.org
similarly if your organisation involves
volunteers in its activities and
services
raths can assist in the promotion of
volunteering vacancies and give guidance
on volunteer management
an extra special easter
more than 500 youngsters enjoyed a day
packed full of fun easter activities in
swain park
rochefort district council's leisure
services team put together the day of
events and activities for youngsters to
coincide with the easter holidays
from arts workshops to face painting to
geocaching there was something for
everyone to enjoy
the fun day also welcomed ex-olympic
fencing international james beavers who
taught youngsters the basics of the
centuries-old sport
there was also judo cricket archery
multi-sports bouncing bunnies an easter
treasure hunt and a guest appearance
from max the dragon to add to the fun
the fun day is part of the council's
holiday activity program that is
delivered in partnership with rochwood
extended services and virgin active
and look
and it looks like there's a busy summer
ahead too
rochford district council in partnership
with rochford extended services and
virgin active will once again be running
a comprehensive program of sports and
arts activities during the summer school
summer holidays
activities will be taking place across
the district from archery to music and
scuba diving to theater
once again rocha district council will
pro will be providing a five-week summer
swim program and there will also be the
return of the popular rochford play
rangers across the district
but please note that once again this
year we will be selling voters for the
summer swim program and no cash payments
can be taken
please check our website and brochure
from mid-june for full details
2012 special offer
as part of rochford district celebration
of london 2012 we're offering one free
place on our summer holiday activities
to anyone born on the 20th of december
ie
2012
proof of date of birth must be provided
and terms and conditions apply
details on all the holiday activity
sessions we provide can be found at www
dot
dot uk
forward slash holiday activities
the nomination process for the fourth
annual sports awards will soon be open
please check www
dot uk for further information or
contact the leisure team on leisure at
rochford.gov dot uk
we're pleased to announce that olympic
badminton star gail ems will be guest of
honor at this year's event which will
take place on thursday the 13th of
october at the mill arts and events
centre in rayleigh
the really windmill will be hosting
various exciting and innovative
exhibitions this season
local artists sandra ray and max dolding
will be displaying their work in
addition to this an exhibition called
journey to the podium celebrating
athletes aiming to compete at the london
2012 games will be on show
this exhibition pairs artists with essex
athletes who have the potential to
compete in the london 2012 games
artwork has been created to celebrate
the athletes achievements and capture
the essence of their personalities and
sport
the exhibition will be in the windmill
from wednesday the 27th of july to mark
a year to go to the london 2012 games
the journey to the podium project has
been awarded the inspire mark which
recognizes projects uniquely inspired by
the olympic and paralympic values
finally sails in the wind the exhibition
celebrating the long and rich history of
the windmill will also be returning
the windmill is open on wednesdays from
10 a.m to 1 p.m and on saturdays and
sundays from 1 p.m to 4pm
please note the windmill will be closed
for private functions on the following
saturdays the 2nd of july 16th of july
20th of august the 3rd 10th and 24th of
september and the 22nd of october so
please check before visiting as these
dates are subject to change and further
additions
for more information on events at the
windmill details on how to get involved
in volunteering or exhibitions at the
windmill please contact the leisure team
on zero one seven zero two
three one eight one nine one or email
leisure
rochford.gov dot uk
in the last edition of rochefort
district matters we told you about
rochford district council's dreams and
memories project being awarded the
london 2012 inspire mark the badge of
the london 2012 inspire program
throughout the spring months the project
has been going from strength to strength
with local children
athletes artists counselors sporting
stars and residents
contributing to a national archive
recording opinions on the london 2012
olympic and paralympic games
the people's record archive is now live
and the rochford project can be viewed
by visiting www.peoplesrecord.org
dot uk
rochford residents have still got time
to add their olympic dreams and memories
to the archive and the leisure team are
running another drop in event as part of
london 2012 open weekend
this will take place on friday the 22nd
of july at clements hall leisure centre
l ss54ln between 10 a.m and 12 noon
anybody interested in taking part should
contact rochford district council's
leisure team on zero one seven zero two
five four six three 366 or leisure
rochford.gov dot uk
and businesses from across rochford have
started sponsoring two of our star
athletes as part of the star at my local
project which is run by rochford
district council shop at my local and
active rochford
wells legal solicitors and wells legal
homes and db training have both signed
up to help two of the district's top
athletes
sailing champion lucy hodges and
badminton star rebecca terry to continue
to excel at the highest level
local businesses that are part of the
shop at my local scheme can get involved
to find out more contact mark oldest on
zero one seven zero two
three one eight one two one or email
mark dot oldest that's
a-l-d-o-u-s
rochford.gov
dot uk